continue with the desinc coms collection
I'm up to number 29 so leading in from
the last video I'll be covering 23 to 29
like always I will be referencing the
previous videos I've made on this Intel
so if you haven't seen them yet I have a
playlist set up and you can find this in
the
[Music]
description
mobile shade servers have been delivered
to all rural outposts and the next
shipment is due to roll off the assembly
line next month they will be installed
at Central hubs in all major
metropolitan areas you don't think
that's Overkill it's a Band-Aid you can
never have enough mandates in a war zone
are you expecting us to be at War soon I
expect that Nat wouldn't be ordering so
many warhounds if she didn't need them
and if she's getting ready for war we
should be too under
understood this Intel is talking about
how mobile shd servers have been
delivered to all rural outposts so my
guess on what they were talking about in
the previous coms about something to do
with farmers and briefcases was somewhat
correct these mobile servers have been
made on mass as a backup to the main
Network they haven't just been
distributed through major cities but
through the countryside too it sounds
like there is an absolute ton of these
around so why in the present day does it
seem like there are very few of these
left the whole last season was about
just one of these
[Music]
servers your AI just got one of my
agents killed hello Cal nice to hear
your voice how is New York Alex what
happened one of my agents broke into a
pharmacy to get painkillers and bandages
for a gunshot wound and your AI marked
her Rogue killed her turret and left her
defenseless I'm sorry to hear that she
she should have used a key I thought
your AI was supposed to be smart my AI
is smart Isaac leaves much to be desired
I can't have my agents left defenseless
because Isaac is a Boy Scout we have a
work around then do it if I allow your
agents to have full access to the system
even if they go Rogue you know what this
means right yes do you also want me to
activate stage one of the hunter
protocol that's the fail safe stage one
only allows you to activate individuals
on a case by case basis if you want them
all online we have to move to stage
three I remember individual Regional
National that's correct just do it this
was never supposed to happen it wasn't
but I'm glad we're ready just in case
you weren't ready this is a show
this this is food poisoning just stay
hydrated and pray this whole thing blows
over in a couple of I don't need the
sales pitch right now Alex I need your
Tech to do his job okay it's
done Rogue agents now have access to
their Tech and if one of them becomes a
problem you can activate a hunter to
dispatch of said problem thank you
Claire I'm sorry yel this is just this
was not where I had planned to be when
this all went down no one expects to be
at Ground Zero but once you're there you
either adapt or die lucky for you you've
got an army to get through before you
die that's not as comforting as you
think Claire if you need anything else
will be in the bunker at least those
systems are working fine thank birdie
for the Power Solutions the defense
systems are really impressive now that
the power is
stable as much as I enjoyed hearing Cal
absolutely loses there is some good
information that has come through this
one the original protocols had the
agents completely cut off from the shd
tech when flagged Rogue and this led to
the death of an agent this answers the
question I've been seeing asked since
the early days of the division 1 why are
rogue agents still able to use their
Tech after they've gone Rogue it also
talks about how limited Isaac can be
when it comes to what is right and wrong
what is on or off Mission I should
have gone Rogue tons of times by now
just from the number of deers I keep
punching alone it's at this moment that
I would have questioned the need for the
Rogue protocol at all given how
sensitive Isaac is think of the number
of agents that have been screwed by
Isaac and be forced into hiding a really
good example of this is in the division
hunted novel without spoiling anything
most non- Rogue agents are in a position
where there are so many super hostile
Rogues that they would rather shoot
Rogues first and ask questions later it
also talks about the hunter protocol it
is a fail safe for rogue agents but it
can't be all Rogue agents their numbers
are too high it's just for the ones who
really develop a name for themselves I
wonder why one was never sent after Kina
the stage 1 to three individual Regional
and National hunted dispatch system is
interesting I wonder why we're currently
sitting in present day and if not
National why not this surely would have
sped up the job for Kelvin and Natalia
or maybe this is just Cal keeping all
his cards close to his chest for now we
also learned that Clea and Alexander
Ortiz were still alive after the
outbreak they have been holding out in a
bunker I wonder if these have anything
to do with the black tus
bunkers this is also the first time we
should have heard about birdie if I had
managed to stay up to date with my disin
comps
the Holograms are not working as
intended we need a more stable power
source Cal says he's working on it I
really hope that doesn't mean what I
think it means you knew that we would
need to bring in additional funding and
Consultants but not him I can't work
with him I know but if you want to get
the new system into production we need
their help Cal promised you can work
directly with birdie you won't have to
see Vic at
[Applause]
all I can work with birdie other than
the power supply any other red flags
from the field test concerned the AI
might be too sensitive and quick to
marking the user off Mission and
removing access to the tech is there an
easy win there yeah we mark them off
Mission but don't kill their access we
alert other users to a Potential Threat
but in case the AI is just being touchy
we allow the user to still have access
to their Tech H Visual and auditory
alert yeah we'll change their UI to red
and eyes will detect the status change
and alert surrounding users will suck
for people who are colorblind or in
certain lighting conditions but the
voice backup should alleviate that issue
a bit it's not perfect but it's better
than killing someone's Tech in the
middle of a firefight because you
accidentally shot a friendly or broke a
door lock to get to cover Isaac can be a
little dactic in his morality this is
why I prefer
Anna we already knew that these comms
went playing out in order and this one
is from quite early on before the
outbreak vickram and his sister birdie
are being brought in as consultants to
assist with power stability he is
certainly hated by the entire franchise
apart from birdie I've had a lot of
people comment on where birdie suddenly
came from at the end of the last man
hunt to be fair Vic sort of just
appeared too yes he screwed us over
early on but we really didn't know
anything about him back then here we can
see that Vic the CEO of AIA Tech
contracted out Power Solutions work
alongside his sister birdie and they
were actually involved with setting up
parts of the Isaac system right at the
beginning since then Vic obviously made
some dumb decisions and went back and
forth screwing over different people
while birdie seems to have just stuck
with Homeland Security work eventually
moving over to Natalia's operations
through Cal's relationship with her we
also find out that they had concerns way
back then about Isaac marking agents's
Rogues too easily and that they'll have
no access to their Tech but for some
reason they didn't follow this up with
Cal
thank you for organizing the testing
facility and granting access to birdie
she really does have a brilliant mind
for this kind of work happy to be of
service I'm honestly surprised how
Hands-On you are with this project when
only a handful of people have the
clearance to support it you have to hold
more hands my hope is to make that a
little easier for you oh I'm working on
a new program that will completely
automate the simulation and training for
your operatives and make it easier for
birdie to do her work independently
anything you can do to make this project
go smoother with fewer hands on deck the
better and whenever you finish those
upgrades Nat is paying for I would be
happy to inherit any of her old and
surplus
toys this quick comms talks about the
simulation clear has developed she is
creating a program that will automate
everything to make things easier for
operative training as well as for birdie
to continue her work there isn't too
much to dissect here but it's certainly
building towards the story of what
descent mode is all
about how did it go terrible they hated
my idea oh don't worry that's not just
you they hate all ideas except their own
birdie birdie doesn't count she's like
some kind of savant or something and
honestly I think she's just so birdie
that it's easier to get out of her way
and let her do whatever crazy ass thing
is in her head it's not fair no it's not
fair fa but a lot of things aren't Fair
it's a solid idea but I need their money
to build the Prototype what's the pitch
terrestrial
firebomb why original concept to deploy
into forest fires to do control burns so
that we don't have to use a smoke jumper
that's a good idea but too philanthropic
for this Bunch find a combat application
and maybe I gave them a combat
application but they said it was too War
crimey they've got automated drones how
is this any more war more crimey than
the they already have in
development it was their idea so of
course it's beyond reproach I hate rich
people here we have Vivian Conley after
pitching an idea to A's robotics this
was obviously before they' canceled her
contract honestly Vivian terrifies me
with how much she's into fire no wonder
she was so at home with the cleaners
later on I mean firebombs really like
napar how would she think this was a
good idea for Homeland Security nothing
screams save what remains like
Napal I do like the comments from the
NSA analyst about birdie though this
kind of confirms a number of things I
said about her in the last man hunt a
genius in her field but struggles with
the social interaction side of
things trust me Cal will buy if we use
Isaac what's the problem with Anna he's
a good old boy you saw how the subjects
responded to the Prototype openly
hostile towards having the female AI
tell them what to do yeah I remember
it's ridiculous and sexist and utterly
disgusting it is but we know that and if
we want to keep funding the development
of the tech we need to secure this
contract and Isaac Isaac will secure the
deal you only like him because he's you
and you prefer Anna cuz she's
you jumping back way before Isaac had
been chosen Clea and Alexander Ortiz
discussed the voice that be given to the
AI system they're developing for Calvin
McManus regardless of what early
subjects have said I get the feeling
that Alexander the cells person in this
relationship would have likely persuaded
Cal in the direction of Isaac anyway
it's kind of funny them saying that
people didn't want to listen to a more
edgy female AI over something like Isaac
when all I see are comments saying that
they wish they could have Anna I kind of
wish my Alexa had the option to turn up
his
sassiness obviously this is nothing on
Brandon kenina the voice behind Isaac he
probably has the most I ionic voice in
the whole
franchise I want you to equip all our
personnel with this new artiz tech you
mean the operatives in the field no I
want you to equip all our Personnel you
don't think that's an invasion of
privacy I don't know what you're talking
about the new Isaac Tech is supposed to
be able to access and data mine all
surveillance equipment and recording
devices it comes into contact with yes
our Personnel are often in civilian
spaces like restaurants and Banks and
theaters if they're wearing this Tech
anyone they come into contact with will
have their data uploaded to Isaac's
system if it actually does what they
promise exactly you don't believe the
tech works as intended I don't believe
and trust in the word of a Salesman who
barely
graduated I don't want to trust in a
belief I want to see test results that
confirm if it's snake oil they're
selling if it's I want to know
will you cancel the contract if we find
the tech doesn't work of course not
if I don't spend my budget I lose my
budget got to keep the wheels of
Congress greased and ready to fund the
new future of warfare you mean security
yes
security if we have this Tech it's only
a matter of time before enemies do
honestly I hope it's otherwise
all our secrets will be for sale to the
highest bidder and the government's
pockets are not that
deep this one is interesting before the
outbreak Cal instructs an NSA analyst to
roll out the new Ortiz Tech to all
Personnel we've discussed the terrifying
aspects of what Isaac can do out in
public previously this is obviously from
before this coms because Cal is now more
than aware of what it's capable of but
what's interesting is that Cal never
actually expected the tech to work this
whole exercise was about spending budget
and politics he needed to spend the
money or he'll no longer receive the
money and as the Secretary of Homeland
Security he needs to show that he's con
L on the edge of the future of warfare
Cal even goes on to say that he hopes it
doesn't work because it wouldn't be long
before the enemies would also develop it
and here is where I should start some
rumors about other countries having
watched the Isaac Anna and the non-ai
diamond program roll out and have
started developing their
own the Division 3 includes a new
hostile faction with Russian or Chinese
Origins and they weld a very similar
looking Tech H Natalia is the daughter
of a Russian G I wonder how much
political influence that gives her in
the
motherland like I said at the beginning
I now have a playlist set up for all of
The Descent comps this includes the
commentary free versions too I've
noticed a lot of you seem to like these
as a reference point so I'll be
uploading the next 10 when I've
collected number 30 next week what do
you think of this batch do you think
there's anything I may have missed let
me know in the comments otherwise I hope
you've enjoyed this and found it
interesting and extremist mice extremer
[Music]
[Applause]
media